In 2019
then Ursula von der leyen and the european parliament
images to vote
for her commissievoorzitterschap they promised
better regulation for companies
they even promised 1 one on out principle
every new EU law had to be removed first
chairman 5 years later,
large companies are leaving us
the manufacturing industry is about to collapse
and almost 1 / 3
of the rules are hardly feasible for our SMEs
that increasingly have to hire expensive consultants
to be able to comply with regulations at all
that drives the already gigantic cost of regulatory burden
on
we want the best social security in Europe
most climate regulations
and if companies make 1 little too much profit
are they dirty
after all,
they mainly have to improve the world
chairman if you promise something
you also have to be paid for
found the slates
promised 1 better investment climate and fewer rules
but only more rules were added
time to settle its policy in June